a vision of britain's green future
whiteley just outside glasgow is the
uk's biggest onshore wind farm a sign of
the changing landscape
but the economic landscape is also
likely to change with new green taxes
and new green tariffs
that could impact all of our lives today
the international trade secretary told
us that among the measures she's
considering
is a carbon border adjustment tax
imposing charges on imports whose
manufacture harms the environment
i'd rather see a multilateral approach
than a unilateral approach of
individual carbon border adjustments it
is certainly
something that we will need to look at
in the future
if it's the case that we don't have
the net zero targets agreed across the
board
while it might be some way off if
implemented this could be a very big
deal indeed
why it all comes back to the line on
this chart uk carbon emissions and look
they're on the way down but here's the
thing our total carbon footprint the
black line is a lot higher
why because all of the carbon intensive
goods we're importing from asia europe
and elsewhere
so while domestic producers have to pay
green levees and obey green regulations
foreign producers sometimes don't that's
where a carbon border adjustment comes
in
making them pay the equivalent costs
when their goods pass the border
now we know government is thinking about
doing it the question
is how soon i think in the real world we
have to appreciate that the eu is moving
ahead unilaterally
with his own carbon border adjustment
mechanism we've seen a proposal from the
democrats in the u.s just this week
of something similar there's also talk
of canada proposing
a carbon border adjustment mechanism
unilaterally as well and in that context
the uk i don't think can afford to put
its head into the head in the sand
that could lead to international tension
here at the bae shipyards in glasgow liz
trust was inspecting the new type 26
frigates
another export of sorts since the
version is being adapted for the
australian navy
for other manufacturers however the real
concern is that if britain pushes onto
net zero
they could lose out to foreign
competitors we entirely support the need
for
carbon fair trade and we want to make
sure that uk manufacturers
who have to bear the uk's carbon costs
don't find themselves
undercut by imports from countries that
don't match the uk's carbon uh ambition
in the end it's about fairness it's all
very well uk companies
going green but if other countries
around the world don't have similarly
strict rules then you run the risk of
this country being flooded with cheap
and pollutive
goods it's essentially the worst of both
worlds you potentially lose domestic
jobs and at the same time you're
indirectly contributing to global carbon
emissions and that
is where this tax comes in for a long
time taxes like this were an academic
fantasy
now as britain reshapes its economic
landscape they are feeling
more and more real ed conway sky news in
glasgow